Most chemists are fascinated by what they've always been told that
HF hydrofluoric acid eats human flesh.
We thought that we should, right.
Obviously we can't try human flesh.
And Brady decided that the chicken's leg that's an
uncooked leg from a dead chicken is a reasonable
approximation to a finger.
We decided that we should try and do a demonstration,
but with some controls so we could compare them.
And what we wanted to know was what was special about HF?
Was it the acid or was it the fluorine?
So we thought if we took two other acids, HCL, hydrogen chloride,
and so Furic acid,
both of those have the H the acid part,
but they don't have the fluorine.
I had been told that HF attacked your
nerves so quickly that if you stuck your finger in it,
and none of us obviously would try this,
that it destroyed the nerves really quickly. So you could hardly feel anything.
There are stories of people whose gloves have leaked,
and they've taken out their hands and bits are missing. And of course,
HIF features in the TV show, breaking bad, which I'm glad to say.
I've never.
Seen, are you glad to say that it's really good? Well.
Perhaps perhaps one day I might watch it when I'm old,
after five minutes, nothing
after half an hour, nothing.
It's just half an hour
at the end of the day, something's likely my truth,
how
we decided to call it today,
but just in case to leave it overnight in the acid in the
morning, it was really nice. Interesting.
The two chicken legs in the control acids,
HCL sulfuric acid had made quite strong color in the
liquid and the bits of the chicken legs sticking out,
still looked quite healthy. You could almost imagine cooking them,
but the leg in the HF was pale. Look,
decidedly dead.
So we lifted them out. The ones in ACL and sulfuric acid.
It turned rather jelly lines.
She's done.
[inaudible].
Really looked almost like an advertisement for being a vegetarian,
really yucky, but with the HF,
it was quite different.
It was as if the surgeon had chopped the bottom off,
it was moderately interesting what has happened below the surface,
but really what was much more interesting to me is why the
chicken leg in HF looked as if it was dead.
And clearly what had happened is that some of the pigments,
some of the red color of the meat had been bleached away.
The reason that meat is red is because it contains
a molecule called myoglobin. This is related to hemoglobin,
which we have in our blood and my globin stores,
oxygen in the muscles.
And my globin is a very similar color to hemoglobin.
If you cook beef roast beef.
So it's rare and red juice comes out. The red juice is my globin.
When in fact it's my globin, that's reactive with carbon monoxide,
which makes it such bright red.
My theory is that the HF
is bleaching away.
That's attacking the structure of the myoglobin in particular,
the so-called hymn group,
the iron porphyrin group in the middle and breaking some of the bonds
so that it no longer absorbs light and is colorless.
And that's why the solution that was left of HF was completely
colorless. It looked as if the stuff had just disappeared.
There wasn't any sludge in the HF peaker.
From school, I thought acid was acid.
And we always learned that H plus is the big deal here and doing all the work,
whether the H plus is coming from hydrochloric acid or sulfuric acid or
hydrofluoric acid, why did they,
why did the three or will do their work so differently?
The reason is that the chicken leg is made up of a
mixture of organic compounds, proteins,
a bit of fat and also bone,
which is a mixture of mineral. Now,
if you break these organic molecules, you are breaking carbon,
hydrogen, carbon, carbon bonds,
and you can't just break them. You have to,
if you like cap them off with some other group and
carbon fluorine bonds of very strong. In fact,
H F is not a very strong acid.
If you dissolve HF in water, especially when it's dilute,
it is not as acid as HCL because the bond
doesn't dissociate the HF bond quite so much,
but hydrogen fluoride HF is very reactive because although
the bond is strong, the bonds in the products that you make are even stronger.
So.
In terms of HF, having a reputation for being a bad boy,
that's really got nothing to do with its acidity or its hydrogen.
It's just the fact that it's got fluorine.
It is because it has got fluorine and it will react very
easily.
So anything with fluorine? No, because.
If you take something with say, carbon fluorine bonds,
the bonds are so strong that it's very difficult to break them.
They are very inert. They used this refrigerants, for example,
because they're very stable.
So it's, so it's a bit like fluorine has come to the dance with hydrogen,
but really it wants to dance with someone else precisely.
Well, it was not so much to dance, but to bond for life.
The reason why I think my explanation is correct is because
we then went the whole hog,
cut the strings and dunked the chicken legs completely in the
acid.